stories from the past
oral culture passed down from one
generation to the next
here in turkey's Kurdish Heartland
there's a long history of struggle that
many say hasn't ended
my life is getting harder day to day as
a Kurdish I can't speak my language on
the streets they are looking at us as a
terrorist
many Kurds are hoping the upcoming
presidential election will bring a
change in leadership they accuse
president recep tayub erdogan of
implementing undemocratic policies the
main Kurdish political force has thrown
its weight behind the candidate fielded
by a six-party opposition Alliance we
need to get rid of toibardon as the
president
is the person who seems to
replacing then
we will have a new ball game we will
have a new process we have a new
historical era but it's an unlikely
Coalition in terms of ideology the
parties that have joined forces have
little in common apart from their goal
to unseat erdogan
uh
the relationship between the opposition
Nation Alliance and HTP is not based on
trust and Kurdish Waters know this but
there is no alternative
party came to power chp-led governments
suppress their rights in the last
election the Party's candidate received
just less than 10 percent of the vote in
Kurdish majority areas
but now CHP leader kilichdar oglo is
saying the right things promising to
resolve Kurdish issues in Parliament and
release political prisoners but not
everyone is convinced
they're using us Kurds all the parties
are trying to benefit from us for
political bargaining
for now many Kurds are focusing on what
their vote can do possibly tip the
balance and what they say is a crucial
ballot and Usher in a new chapter in the
country's history
Southeast turkey
so I really